if you're anywhere near El Paso Texas
there's a one-day apologetics and
evangelism conference this month
Saturday September 14th 2024 I asked the
organizers what they wanted me to speak
about they said they wanted me to share
how I became a Christian now in my mind
I already made an awesome video about
that while walking through the subway
system of New York I made it awesome so
that I wouldn't need to tell that story
anymore if anyone asked I could say
watch the video but Texans want to hear
me say it in person for some reason and
you know what they say Don't Mess with
Texas so I'll be sharing my testimony
but I don't want to say the same thing
as my video so maybe I'll go a little
deeper share some details people haven't
heard before anyway if you're free hope
to see you there
unless you're Mike Winger in which case
you're banned from the
conference details are in the
description box
[Music]